معنى منوديسا ديمترو بليتشنكوك المتحدث
باسم قياده القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه
المسلحه يعني
[موسيقى]
ما هو الدور الذي لعبتموه في الهجوم على
السفينه الروسيه وهو ما تتهمون به في اطار
ما يبدو انه استهداف
متبادل في البحر
اننا لسنا خائضين في اي اضرار ضد هذه
السفينه في البحر الاسود
ونعلم ونؤكد ان
السفينه الانزال الروسيه قد تعرضت لاضرار
وهي الان تعود الى الميناء المخصص لها في
نظر
يعني هذه السفينه تضررت في خليجي نوفو
سيسكو
ويعني انتم الان يعني هل هل يتجه الامر
الى ان الطرفين يستهدفان القوات البحريه
حتى لو كانت مدنيه
ويستهدفان الموانئ لكلا الجانبين هل هذا
المسار الذي تاخذه الحرب الان
[موسيقى]
دون اي خلاف يجب ان اقول ان اوكرانيا لا
تقوم باستهداف اي سفن مدنيه او اي اساطير
اخرى ولا تهاجم الموانئ المدنيه حتى وان
كانت تحت الاحتلال في مناطقنا في القرب
مثلا طبعا اعود لموضوع السفينه هناك مصادر
اعلاميه وتحديدا رويترز هي التي ذكرت ان
القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه
بالمشاركه مع جهاز الامن الاوكراني هي
التي نفذت العمليه في نوفو روسيسك
فهل فهل كان هناك اي اي نوع من الاستهداف
سواء منكم او اي جهاز امني اخر
يجب ان اقول ان الحادث المذكور حدث في
المياه وليس في الموانئ الشيء الثاني لا
استطيع ان اؤكد ان القوات البحريه هي من
قامت بهذا لاننا لم نقم بهذا
طبعا تعلم ان وسائل الاعلام الروسيه نشرت
مشاهد قالت انها للسفينه عسكريه روسيه
وقالت انها تضررت نتيجه الهجوم الاوكراني
في البحر الاسود انت تعلم هذا وربما شاهدت
هذه اللقطات اليس كذلك
قد تكون تقصد ليست السفينه الحربيه بل
تقصد الباخره المدنيه نعم سفينه ليست
باخره مدنيه سفينه عسكريه روسيه تضررت
نتيجه هجوم اوكراني في البحر الاسود وهذه
مشاهد مسارتها وسائل اعلام روسيه ماذا
تقول عن هذا الهجوم وهذه المره لن نتحدث
عن سفينه عسكريه وليست مدنيه
من الممكن ان نؤكد انه فعلا كان هناك
سفينه انزال كبيره قد تضررت وهذا نؤكده
ولكن هذا تم دون اي تدخل من طرفنا
في في توازن القوى في حرب ما يبدو انها
حرب موانئ كيف تصفون قدراتكم البحريه
نحن نعمل على الدفاع عن
موانئنا ضد الهجمات الروسيه الهجمات التي
تستخدم بها الصواريخ والمسيارات في هذه
الاوقات نحن لا نقوم بهجمات ضد بنيه تحتيه
مدنيه او موانئ العدو
شكرا جزيلا لك
المتحدث باسم قياده القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه المسلحه